I kind of breezed through a very  important turning point and thank you  for chapter four for pointing it out it  does look like a kind of a weird-ish  Miss because it's maybe what he didn't  like was the idea of Rook takes C5 King  E5 from Q8 check but  there's surely a bit of calculation here  should be enough King D5 I think D5  feels very clear yeah it feels like yes  black will probably pick up something  maybe even the entire King side but  all we need to do is to play King B5 C5  C6 and then the game ends pretty much  because none of your choices will be any  good or rookie one is seven in it even  yeah yeah so I guess yeah maybe maybe he  just decided he will win without having  to calculate at any point but that is  often  not how it works out  elmas versus barbadam is still  continuing sort of very much along the  way of  how these lines generally develop both  both sides are  uh